this was the moment the explosion
happened in central Istanbul in the
middle of Sunday afternoon video filmed
in the immediate aftermath shows bodies
lying still on the ground and people
shouting to help for the wounded as the
Smoke Clears
it happened near taxim Square on a busy
street one of the main shopping streets
in the city and popular with tourists a
number of foreigners are understood to
have been caught in the explosion
the Turkish president typed Richard
erdogan spoke briefly on National
Television before flying to the G20
leaders Summit in Indonesia
our nation should be sure that the
perpetrators will be punished as they
deserve by uncovering all the elements
that led up to this incident on Easter
Cloud Street
this is the first major terror attack in
Istanbul for five years after Kurdish
militants and Islamic State separately
targeted the city in a series of attacks
between 2015 and 2017.
presidential elections are next year
often a tense time in Turkey
and this attack could harm the tourist
market so vital at the moment with
Turkey's economy in a desperate way
Alistair bunkel Sky News